je ne
je
salut à tous cette semaine on vous parle
d'un mode de déplacement écologique et
économique par excellence 1780 licenciés
26 clubs 3 vélodrome et pour nous en
parler
landel félix ta passion c'est quoi félix
c'est le vélo bien sûr le cyclisme le
cyclisme évidemment c'est parti
félix est un incontournable du cyclisme
local sportif avec ses 150 km par
semaine
engagé au sein de ce club de l'est c'est
un maillon fort du cyclisme réunionnais
c'est vrai ça vraiment à peu près de
quarante ans maintenant on faisait un
peu de vélo comme ça peut aller chercher
le pain pour aller à l'école pour se
déplacer normalement
une association s'est créée à bras panon
dans les années soixante treize et je me
suis dit pourquoi pas moi aussi fait un
petit peu de vélo avec les copains pour
s'entraîner pour blaye et ça s'est fait
tout seul ça s'est fait tout seul par
l'amour du vélo
et puis de rendre un petit peu ce que
nous on a eu quand on était jeune
aux exercices de la faire surtout au
passage bas une fois à droite et à
gauche
si tu mets la mer bat va reste sur la
bonne jumeaux d'accord allez c'est parti
je vais le club de l'est et le club
formateur par exellence plusieurs fois
champion de france et même si les règles
ont changé au niveau national leur
travail de terrain reste une référence
cd des exercices de maniabilité
cela permet de
de bien se déplacer à vélo d'être
commandé de rouler en sécurité s'il ya
quelque chose d'imprévu cariven
n'importe quoi qui peut arriver ça leur
permet de contrôler leur levée le vélo
sans s'affoler à la basse à l'école du
cyclisme c'est ça comprend les je
t'adresse tout ça il a donc voilà donc
les gamins de bruit très bien vous êtes
quoi vous êtes dont on est fou
la chaussée
genou